[Music]
in one in 50 million news your chances
of being a sperm that becomes a baby or
becoming a redhead perhaps how did you
know know submitted by no shoes no
service formidable rule what's that song
no shirt no shoes that's a song service
yeah that's a LMFAO it is I don't know
you're cooling me you're younger than me
I'm listening to the same iTunes from
2003 yep
Alisa Eminem show all day this important
yep a woman lived for 99 years with her
organs in all the wrong places but never
knew it [ __ ] what about the extra year
to make her she died before them so they
did I opted up him to say and then they
realized their hearts in her [ __ ] but
exactly as slave was she alive no at all
knowing that no she was so she died as
she like damn the puss it was all up in
her armpit or [ __ ] love was in a
[ __ ] leg do you think the autopsy
guys like you know Brett come to check
this [ __ ] out [ __ ] nipples on her
feet because there were students that's
a glitch in the system you're not a
catch this person so you just like treat
them like they're cadavers yeah they're
cadaver donate a body exactly so she
donated her body to research at a
university in Portland Oregon she passed
away in October 2017 from natural causes
the students didn't know anything about
her they were so shocked to find out
that she had things and like in verse
you have a heart problem but really yes
sir your foot problems kidney is up here
what if they got all bad grades because
they're like that's not worth everyone's
bodies like be like cut her open right
and then they accidentally like knock
her body over on the ground like I'll
ship in the back end oh no so she had
this congenital disease I don't know
condition and so um it was called situs
inversus
with level cardio which like a Harry
Potter's ball yeah I just
your kids are [ __ ] spear
it means that her liver stomach and
other abdominal organs were reversed
right to left so like the mirror image
of a typical human and big found out
because in her heart it was in the
normal position but when the students
were looking for a particular major vein
it was in the wrong place it was just
everything was just flipped it was a
vessel meaning too bad people didn't
know about it when she was alive so she
couldn't she didn't get bullied for it
sure you get point for your internal
organs so she went through life without
getting bullied but her flaw was too
covered hey how come you're right lungs
in your left lung hey freak
yeah situs inversus with level cardia is
rare occurring about once and every
22,000 births and normally it's
associated with life-threatening heart
issues and other abnormalities
absolutely so usually these the people
that have this like they don't really
live that long and like the oldest
patient there were two other cases where
the patient's reached the age of 70 and
those were like what but she was 99 what
she died it's because they don't build
people like they used to that goes all
people are Hardy man no I don't think
our generations gonna live to a hundred
like naturally we're gonna have so much
technology and [ __ ] to help oh we should
get our organs switch like her so we
live longer dude we're gonna [ __ ]
nanomachines and [ __ ] bro yeah we're
gonna have like [ __ ] fake eyes that
can zoom in on [ __ ] I can't wait for
this katway sign me up I want to have
super legs and on no but you're gonna
have to learn an app to use it I'll
learn it for that [ __ ] Oh like I'm done
learning
I don't wanna learn any more things that
are technology but think about how easy
tech is now you just download an app in
your phone and then you're good goal
yeah I want to learn all stuff like how
to craft a sword yeah but wouldn't you
could do that like I want to take a
blacksmith in class you should do these
why don't you do that like matrix-style
and download it yeah and you're ready
[ __ ] good yeah how much a pain in the
ass is learning the most pain in the ass
now you can download that [ __ ] I want my
computer to learn it
and then I just hit a button exactly
that's why I don't think we'll be like
Wally and everyone saying would be all
fat on the chairs and [ __ ] I think that
we'll have machines that will do
everything for us include working out
for us those will be all be hot and all
all the people will be called do you
think they'll have the thing like in
black we're we're like you can pick who
you're [ __ ] like you know like you're
[ __ ] me but I'm watching a picture of
someone else like my face is a green
screen and like you can put on anything
no like they like the green video it's
in their eyeballs where they can like
change the picture to be like a memory
of somebody to be able to her our bodies
so you can [ __ ] Ryan Gosling well I'm
[ __ ] Ryan Gosling yeah that would be
really tiring Oh would be tight she died
yeah she was ela Oh 911 so strong she
was 11 Benjamin Button
thankin oh wow it's hot hey what'd the
doctors ever know if her organs were
reversed
yeah so they were saying that she had
had three surgeries before and one of
them was her appendix and the surgeon
did just casually mention like well that
wasn't where it was supposed to be no
was it well but they only know they
opened her up
yeah so that's how they found out cuz
they were doing an autopsy or like a
like students just looking dissecting
it's not like her titties were in the
one spot what although I'm sure they
were when she was older but yeah like
her liver I wish they would color code
at the same so we could tell like oh boy
holy I can't even tell what's going on
dude I'm like yeah I believe yeah that
could be me that's squiggles difficult a
heart condition
what do you got a heart murmur banging
[ __ ] it's minor but if it skips a beat
I'm dead
what's heart murmur regular heartbeat
yeah you know some doctors I'm surprised
you read what a fault sometimes you told
me that I had that when I was 16 yeah
and I never really looked into it and
I'm just like well it's a heart murmur
my heart skips a beat sometimes then why
don't you die you say because the venom
might not beat me anymore ah my heart
used to speed up and then it would stop
I like defect to normal no no to speed
up randomly is it when you were on
treadmill because it should do that no
it was before I started drinking at
Monster energy drinks but then after I
did I'm not even kidding
like after I started drinkin Monster
energy drinks when I was doing an improv
it stopped doing that [ __ ] has a funny
story that my mom's doesn't know so in
high school my friend we got a little
like wrestle match thing you know it's
like for fun I think I passed them and
in the hallway of the school and then he
kind of got me in a headlock sir you
can't super than you wrestled I dunno
hey I locked me and then I passed out
cuz it's too tight and I tabbed and he
didn't know and then they took me to the
doctors and my mom was like oh what
happened I don't know I passed out and
then they put this heart monitor on me
and I was like this big ass rectangle
square and I said sleep with it for like
three days and then they found out
that's when my irregular heartbeat was
yeah I wish that you just described like
a high school fight that you my mom
still think that you know I just passed
out his [ __ ] I never told her did you
should tell her the truth because she's
worried heart murmurs are sounds during
your heart beats cycle such as whooshing
or swishing made by turbulent blood and
or near your Bloods turbulent hot blood
I don't have any medical problems heart
murmurs sometimes they may be harmless
also called innocent or abnormal yeah
what about a heart flutter
I think that's worse heart barbar
nervousness right maybe no or like
anxiety has it and I think I have it but
I don't part palpation my dad has that
[Music]
yeah my dad was a horrible 32-hundred
skipping a beat one which one
station that the heart is racing
pounding fluttering or skipping a beat
often fathers what about heart to heart
Lee ever a sign of heart disease your
heart that's not what I have what about
heart to heart your likes me hard time I
did a lot of [ __ ] drugs I don't know
why I'm not [ __ ] up like [ __ ] in my
body you are and what we don't know cuz
you were young mom and then we'll find
out like oh yeah what doctor it stomachs
when I was 30 and I was like look I want
to start working out but I want to make
sure that I'm not [ __ ] up and then
they checked out my vitals and it's like
oh yes I just [ __ ] smoking I was like
unhealthy and in their life
oh actually you have like a heart like
what do you call it the blood pressure
heart being as a of an athlete I don't
like what the [ __ ] cuz I am better than
people who don't smoke I was like what
just love you and your stupid foster
story
hell yeah cuz I thought I was gonna be -
like I'm like you know like you're not
supposed to immediately go through
rigorous exercise out of nowhere
cuz it's dangerous you know I have a
health thing that I'm like I don't know
what it is and doctors don't know what
it is either it's like sometimes ever
since I was like a kid I got a five when
I first felt it but I randomly
throughout the years there's nothing
that really triggers it but I don't know
where I'll get this like stabbing pain
in my chest cavity and I don't know
and it hurts more when I'm breathing
yeah I've gotten that the [ __ ] is
Costco chondrite us what is it oh [ __ ]
me god I had a heart attack REM oh I
thought so he's a tendon in your ribs
and it's just like that and it hurts
like [ __ ] yeah and it's like when you
move or when you breathe it hurts hold
on what it was I'm like the [ __ ] this
feels like a heart attack
no it is it their symptoms are the same
that's why I find it was like it can
either be this one or it could be a
heart attack so I went into the ER and
then they're like yeah inflammation of
the cartilage that connects a rib to the
breastbone
yeah how did you know how to spell that
[ __ ] that's insane it heard me oh I just
put cost and then it popped up Wow
what about the one where your
bellybutton start seeing randomly and
like she says what dog seriously what
have you thought that before yeah what
is that [ __ ] I don't know I felt that
sorry you guys are gonna die is that
Costco contrariness or whatever no cuz I
felt it didn't in your bellybutton right
in a day it's inside yeah I felt that
day I'm not shooting pain yeah it's not
a thing it's shooting you know Leila's
stabbing you inside the hole no [ __ ] no
yeah it's like when you could hop out of
here just fat mmm yeah look that [ __ ] up
it just goes away I hate it yet to
prevent it hasn't happened in a few
years I don't know I think drinking a
lot of water helps a lot of water and
working out helping me care a lot of
[ __ ] pain I'm so glad you tell me
about this yeah this has been a mystery
of my body my whole life you didn't you
never went to a cool doctor before with
sunglasses on I know the cool nurse
[Music]